[Music]
so what do you think the u.s looks like
in five years
if we could paint a picture
oh sure
it's
like
blm and jan sixth
all the time
or let's say much more you mean in terms
of events or in terms of discussion
in terms of
like there will be mobs that are
gathered online there will be it's like
stochastic network warfare between two
groups
that would be uh so is it five years
might be ten years i don't know the
exact time frame it could happen faster
could happen slower but fundamentally i
think the catalyst is if you look at
interest rates and you look at the graph
have you ever look at look at like the
long-term graph of interest rates
yeah i have actually but uh we should
put it in the show notes for people we
should put in the show notes i just want
to find this graph a long-term chart
okay so if you go to this graph and you
click max
all right so this is trading economics
dot com slash united hyphen states slash
interest
hyphen rate
yeah so united states interest rate
united states fed funds rate
tradingeconomics.com right i'm looking
at max okay and so what do you see you
essentially see something where
over a
40-year time frame
you have like
a trend which is very much down and to
the right
yeah yep
and
what that is is it's basically something
where one of the things i write about
and dalio's actually also talked about
this
there are trends that affect humans
that are
longer than the cycles that we're
intuitively familiar with
for example you're familiar with the
cycle of your breath that's a few
seconds right you're familiar with the
day you're familiar with
you know
basically the seasons of a year
and that's actually what most people are
familiar with beyond that maybe the
election cycle you know in four years or
the longest thing somebody might be
familiar with frankly are venture
capital funds or startups which are like
10-year cycles that might be the longest
thing where you can run an experiment
and see a few reps of it in a five or
ten year time frame over your life right
a venture capitalist might see hundreds
or thousands of five or ten year long
experiments that most people don't
really don't really track things over
that time frame and any normal human
cannot really track things over 40 or 50
years you have to kind of dedicate your
life to that right same thing that's
happening over multiple decades you
really need really good charts and stuff
to see what the heck is happening this
graph is one of the best and most
important because it's so unambiguous
and what it shows is essentially that
the u.s economy we have run out of
juice
the federal reserve being able to print
money and so on it just keeps going down
on this trend like interest rates and
if you notice every time they try to
jack it up it has to be
pushed back down and kept down for
longer and longer and longer right if
you're seeing that in that graph yeah
and now the next time when they're
they're going to be forced probably to
bring interest rates all the way to the
floor maybe before the 2024 election and
i think you will see
very serious inflation as a function of
that because they'll print money
and will actually have genuine goods
shortages
because we have all these supply chain
things that are hitting you have china
doing its crazy
stuff with it with the ports and
the the the coveted lockdowns you have
the
do you know the slow steaming
regulations
i do not know the slow steaming
regulations
basically like some esg thing this is a
great example of how like moral
you know the moral flipping
i'm getting this second hand so i might
have it
wrong but
i believe it is
reducing the speed of cargo ships to cut
down carbon emissions right okay let me
just define two things real quickly so
you mentioned dalio just for people who
don't know ray dalio former
let's just call him head principal at
bridgewater associates at least at the
time that i interviewed him largest
hedge fund in the world about 175
billion or something like that esg
environmental social and governance
factors so just that bleeds into the
what you were just discussing so please
continue
that's right so just to summarize it
basically we have more money they'll
eventually need to print again we have
literally fewer goods where china's
cutting off supply there's sanctions
there's wars like ukraine there are
coveted lockdowns
there's stuff like slow steaming which
is this huge self-inflicted wound by the
esg thing where every single container
ship in the world has to slow down now
right so you have
a lot of things that can sum up into
something where it gets non-linear fast
and
if that happens and you do have not just
the inflation we have now but genuine
serious inflation or even hyperinflation
that is when society comes apart in the
us because
i mean people have been so freaking
angry at each other during the 2010s in
a relatively booming market
right like in the 2010s up until 2019
things were like decent economically but
man were people mad at each other and
when there's like actual genuine
scarcity if that does happen if physical
goods are hard to come by and your
inflation you know inflation's destroyed
your currency and so on and you have a
country where people are heavily armed
and they're yelling at each other on
social media and you've got 50 governors
like
you've got a very potent cocktail for
bad things and we've sort of seen this
in lots of other countries
that
frankly america was involved in in you
know partially destabilizing like look
at libya or something like that
or mexico or what have you but that
people just really do believe on some
level quote it can't happen here
but i think american anarchy
unfortunately
is is sort of where we're heading
what exactly does that mean you know try
and paint a picture so first of all
in 1861 if you go and look at
the map in 1861 you have the
union and you have the confederates and
it's the ideological and the
geographical coincide right you have the
north and you have the south and we take
for granted that the victory condition
was for the north to just invade the
south and because by invading their
capital and burning and so on they
didn't just destroy their supply chain
they also killed their morale and
eventually they got the entire south to
concede and they could flip them
ideologically and you know emancipation
proclamation reconstruction they
uninstalled the software in their heads
and installed software with new moral
premises same in world war ii invade
nazi germany denotify them capture the
capital the ideological and geographical
coincided and that's how we think of
wars as working
now
today though if you go and look at a map
of the us and you look at republican
democrat
it's not like in clean states it's very
fractal it's at the individual county
level you've got little red here a
little you know blue here purple here
it's extremely
grouped together it's fractal
and so that means is that in physical
space these two nations are cheek by gel
but in digital space
as a as that graph i showed you show
those two social networks are just
clustered apart in digital space right
they're they're separated in digital
space did i show you that graphic did
you see it yeah i got this one we'll put
this in the show notes for everybody
so when you see that graph you're like
oh okay so in physical space people are
cheeked by gel but in digital space
they're far apart and that's where the
battlefront is right and you can
reconceptualize the last several years
as a social war
okay because if in a physical war the
goal is to invade territory in a social
war the goal is to invade minds and now
when we think about cancellation
d-platforming hashtags etc etc the point
is that what you're trying to do is get
a node on their side to flip from blue
to red or red to blue and how do you do
that because they're now uttering your
hashtag slogan right blm or mega or
something like that they're uttering
that slogan that node is flipped it's
like capture the flag you're seeing from
their utterance that they are saying the
thing that indicates they're now on your
team right they're raising a flag over
their company etc and
you are able to cancel and silence those
people who are saying things that are
contrary to your view and so on and so
forth it is essentially something where
because you are constrained from using
physical violence
since what are you going to invade a
cornfield invade a city that doesn't
actually work
you're winning digitally it's digital
warfare right now when i say constrained
from using physical violence as we've
seen that's actually less of you know
we're starting to see stochastic digital
violence
the proud boys and antifa and so on
punching it out in the street that's
actually
an extremely unusual thing in the 90s
and 2000s america you just never saw
like left and right-wing militias
punching it out in the streets but you
see that now that's actually something
which is
de rigueur i don't know we're on the
100th or 300th it's like it's like an
event you wouldn't be like totally
shocked that that's happening that
political violence is happening in
america but it is
and it's on a ramp
and so you put all that together and
basically what i see is
serious inflation
bitcoin mooning
and then the u.s government trying to
freeze or seize the bitcoin with
something that's similar to executive
order 6102
you